(Transcribed by TurboScribe.ai. Go Unlimited to remove this message.) Добре.
Взагалом почнемо, тоді я бачу у нас є
обидві команди, почнемо з першої команди.
Взагалом хотілося би поговорити, вперше вказати, що у
нас буде в п'ятницю найближче, так як
це в нас вже кінець спринту, тому у
нас буде саме такий огляд того, що було
зроблено, які були проблеми і, можливо, які будуть
покращені.
Ми глянемо, що було зроблено, які моменти можливо
змінити, прибрати, виправити, чи було взагалі багато завдань,
тобто дискусії такого типу.
Я, по-перше, бачив, що в Асані в
першій, в другій команди не були, ну хоча
б я не бачив ніякої роботи з завданнями,
тому, можливо, є з цим якісь проблеми, чи
взагалі є якийсь прогрес з проєктами.
Ми зараз дизайн робимо, тому ми думали спочатку
вже зробимо хоч щось, а потім вже туди
завантажимо.
Дивіться, зараз я включу демонстрацію.
Добре, не так, все добре.
Зараз лише починаємо.
Дивіться, в Асані, в чому основна ідея?
Чи видно екран?
Добре, дивіться, загалом, що було б можна зробити?
Більше для візуалізації.
Я розумію, що ви працюєте над дизайном, це
чудово, це гарна ідея.
Наприклад, для того, щоб більш-менш розуміти, хто
працює на чим, щоб ми могли в п
'ятницю, наприклад, подивитись.
Ви можете зайти на ваш проєкт, наприклад, ми
дивимося, команду першу зараз, і тут є розробити
дизайн шапки блогу.
Тут є Асані, тобто той, хто робить це,
і ви можете натиснути і поставити себе, якщо
це ви робите або це ваш одногрупник робить.
І таким чином тут так само є розробити
дизайн сторінки блогу.
Ви можете почати з цієї частини, користувацькі історії
ви можете ігнорувати, а завдання ви можете пообирати,
хто з чим працює, щоб було більш-менш
зрозуміло.
Або, наприклад, якщо ви створили репозиторій в GitHub
'і вже, то ви можете також назначити себе
і примістити його в зроблене, наприклад.
Тобто, щоб в нас був приблизний огляд того,
який є прогрес над проєктом.
Або, якщо ви це розробляєте, то поки що
backlog-спринту – це всі завдання, які в
нас є на двохтижневий період розробки.
Якщо ви взяли, наприклад, я себе зараз назначу,
як приклад, так бачите, що вказано, що це
я, і я можу там перевести завдання в
процес розробки.
І я над ним працюю.
Тобто, це більш основна ідея, щоб можна було
легше бачити і вам все ж таки легше
презентувати, які частини були зроблені в п'ятницю,
наприклад.
Тому що в п'ятницю у вас буде
якраз таки можливість і показати приблизно, що у
вас є Сергію Оцієвичем.
Тобто фактичне спілкування з клієнтом і вільність обговорення
стосовно, що можливо треба було б доробити або
що змінювати.
Тобто було б добре, можете спробувати зробити цю
частину.
Знову ж таки, якщо, наприклад, у вас немає,
ви робите якийсь дизайн, якого тут немає, ви
можете створити завдання, тут є ось add task,
ви натискаєте і просто описуєте, який дизайн ви
створюєте.
І назначаєте до себе.
Тобто таку частину цілком добре було б зробити.
Можете спробувати, хоча б можете просто порозділяти завдання
приблизно по тому, хто що робить, і далі
попередности їх, наприклад, в процес розробки.
Просто для видимості.
Ця частина зрозуміла?
Чи, можливо, є якісь питання?
Так, добре, зрозуміло.
Стосовно розробки, чи є якісь, можливо, проблеми, незрозумілості,
щось потребує присни, допомоги?
Поки немає.
Чудово, якщо тоді старшої команди немає питань, давайте
тут другий.
Я бачу, Олександр є.
Ну, загалом, Олександр, я думаю, що до вас
теж саме буде прохання.
Я бачу, у вас також тут кубка є
завдань.
Тобто спробуйте їх пообирати кожен, хто займається розробкою.
У вас, щонайменше, має бути троє чи четверо
людей.
Тому можете собі пообирати завдання і попередности їх
в процес розробки, або зроблено, якщо ви їх
зробили.
І, загалом, чи є якісь проблеми, незрозумілості, чомусь
потребуєте допомоги?
Поки немає ніяких.
Добре.
Я зупиню демонстрацію екрану.
Загалом, як і обговорювали в п'ятницю тоді,
до п'ятниці було б добре, знову ж
таки, більше, як рекомендації, щоб показати можна було
щось.
Загалом, навіть якщо у вас є просто дизайн,
це також добре.
Тобто ви можете його показати клієнту або Сергію
Оцієвичу і, загалом, тоді вже обговорити, які будуть
виправлені, чи, можливо, все йому подобається.
Тобто, щоб ми могли бачити щось.
Така чтина була б добре.
Але, знову ж таки, якщо не буде можливості,
то в цьому теж немає ніякої проблеми.
Добре, ми зрозуміли.
Ну, загалом, тоді, я думаю, можна зупинити запис.